hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play baby blues and
I know that you guys have been
suggesting this for a long time and I've
been trying to get it to work for a long
time okay
anyway oh wow hold up hold up game I
haven't even gotten in yet calm down the
descent into insanity called cool it
Derek I realized that finally it took me
a long time to realize this but my my
antivirus was secretly deleting files
every time I extracted something so a
lot of games that have been trying to
play have been unstable because they're
missing files basically it's along in
the short of it what games wouldn't
start at all if games actually did start
they would crash later because of that
so I toned down my antivirus
okay so let's get into it so glad that
it's finally working because mostly it's
FPS creator games it I haven't been
working as well as they should have I
don't know if it's like some part of it
is its self extracting as soon as you
use the XE or something like that I'm
not actually sure but every one thing
should be working hunky-dory okay
okay all right I've intentionally
avoided seeing any videos of this game
so I'm going into this as blind as I
usually go into games
hello I believe that this is made by the
same guy that made rec shutter which I
played before people have suggested that
I play but I've already played it so
here we go and this is not the other
game called among the sleep which is
based off of the same idea where you're
a kid wandering through your house okay
need to find 9 teddy bears and obviously
you're a baby in a haunted house so I
don't think you could be any more
helpless can this baby run has he
learned how to run yet so why this baby
decides to wander around in the middle
of the night and find teddy bears is
beyond me but alas I will I will
persevere I'm trying to say what a weird
place for a couch or chair oh I do not
like this already
ha ha ha I don't know if there's a
monster stalking the halls I would
imagine there would be of some sort
there usually is in these games ok ah
why was yo mama's rooms key in the
bathroom
seems a little strange don't you think
it's really dark wait I'm the baby why
am i doing that interesting how the
Lightning lit up this area when there
are no windows nearby hello media room
why would there be a media room
no thank you
I'd rather not holy crap
I can't see anything the lighting is not
that great in this house I don't see a
teddy bear there might be one in here I
just don't see it I'm just clicking
around randomly in the darkness but um
I'm gonna get the hell out of here man
yeah I'm a sphere in this game was very
very very Oh is that I saw something in
the darkness you can't tell me I don't
see something there's something out
there
what is that
what was I good God
ah I've heard that before
I've used that before okay so okay okay
person kay hey I saw something in the
darkness I did I did you can't tell me I
didn't I know what I saw it was
something leaning over that teddy bear
is that another teddy bear no that's not
those are daddy shows oh this kid must
have a messed-up childhood for him to be
oh so strangely affected now that's more
like it
lightning narrowly window still haven't
found many teddy bears either this house
is much bigger than I think okay I
present Kai it no work maybe that means
I need a key
probably I'm guessing K means key and I
need key I guess it goes outside I'm not
exactly sure it's gonna be hard to find
the keys because one it's really dark
and two they're on the ground and are
tiny they're itty bitty itty bitty bitty
bitty bitty
I still say I saw something in the
darkness
you all saw something too don't deny hey
you son of a [ __ ]
Oh his daddy's office where he makes the
money
I noticed that wake you late I saw that
I saw that take the teddy bear yes plea
why what what does that say we are near
weawy weawy weawy weawy weawy is that
French for yes oh that's a chair I
thought I saw something else in the
darkness god damn it [ __ ] you mother God
Jesus tell you that's so cheap
oh so cheap oh so cheap
stop it that was so cheap that's not
fair that's not fair that was not fair
why can i push this this is still locked
yeah I need a key oh god that was so
cheap it's not fair man don't do that to
me
Kat went that way see if I can go down
this way no oh man
god I can't do that to me teddy bear I
wouldn't have even known that the litter
was one up there how would I it's too
high for me to see there another teddy
bears some huh huh how I would have
never known that was one up there
I cannot see a thing
shut up no no stop bad worry Bailey
there gotta be there maybe there had to
be a teddy bear in here and I just
missed it I think I would think what's
that oh yeah I knew there had to be a
teddy bear in there somewhere
good job scar you son of a [ __ ] ha if
I'm screaming constantly they can't
turtle me
I wanna go home I'm home what am I
talking about okay oh hang a hand there
was another way to go yeah this hallway
down here okay so I just came from there
I went in the bathroom there wasn't
anything in the bathroom besides a key
let me double check just to be sure
though I've got four teddy bears that's
good right that's good I'm doing great
yeah totally totes mix croats bread
maybe those a teddy bear in the toilet
that I missed teddy bear behind the
toilet nope okay I got everything from
the bathroom I need to find Mama's room
I would assume that Mama's room would be
by the baby's room but then again I
might be wrong
spoiled brat has nine teddy bears I
didn't even have one when I was growing
up at deprived childhood okay what is
this why is it so bright here guess I
shouldn't be complaining okay this is
the beginning this is the bright happy
beginning
what did hmm why did go god I need nine
Teddy's first okay alright we're okay oh
boy I hear that God think I don't Oh God
shut up baby okay here we go
this Mama's bedroom Mama's kind of
messed up in the head I'm imagining hmm
where but wait was that me
am i sub soda possessed demon devil
probably now to explain a lot
I've seek a twist of stories I've
actually killed everyone in the house
shop there I don't even see that it's
it's so damn dark I couldn't I wouldn't
have ever been able to see that I
imagine there's got to be like another
key in here to somewhere there's gotta
be he that I can't see can't jump can't
see
I got no hops I need my mad hops bread
to see above these chairs and desks it's
gotta be something else in here I know
that's gotta be oh go away go away
please I don't want any do not want any
ice okay I don't think there's anything
else in here hi go away go away sir push
you to the corner and never look at you
ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever
again
okay we're doing good I guess got five
five teddy bears
I've teddy bears and that's supposed to
make me feel better I guess
still really dark can't see [ __ ] been in
there got the teddy bear there was no
key Oh what is this wait where am I
I can't see anything I'm just fumbling
around in the darkness I'm guessing
that's the point but I still don't like
it okay there's still these locked doors
that I haven't been able to open or find
a key for cuz the keys are imperceptibly
small and in the darkness they don't
glow or anything yeah maybe there had to
be something else in daddy's office wait
I didn't go this way what is this why
just like the front door some key on
them under the mat or something god it's
so bloody dark who's that
and there's that deep rumble in the
background going with a pant plane
outside
Oh
like this I don't like any of this
haha I just want to get this over with
Oh what's this I knew it knew there had
to be a key take yes take washroom key
okay I got a key we are near good for
you go to hell
die please watch room I'm guessing that
means a laundry room you in Canada the
washroom is the bathroom in America will
about the bathroom is a weird American
colloquialism it doesn't make sense
because when we say bathroom we mean
case never mind I don't care enough I'm
just rambling
okay why are there so many Krebs says
it's small there doesn't seem to be
anything actually in here ah kitchen key
maybe well there's no teddy bear [ __ ] me
what what that I can I guess that's
leaning oh come on there's got to be
something else in here besides just
another key what's the point
oh so many these damn rocking horses
okay I didn't see anything
where'd I come from
Daigo to hell and you die okay let's
find the kitchen get out here I think
the kitchen is on the other side of
Daddy's office
why do I keep calling a daddy's office
that's really weird
over this way
to the kitchen on the way to the kitchen
oh not again
haha oh [ __ ] you good timing though
that's what I was going for
oh [ __ ] you oh man I guess there's not
like a monster stalking the halls which
is good ah camo look you can't move that
was bull now it's even darker I
literally can't see [ __ ] how am I
supposed to find anything when it
why one care another key um hmm
six of nine teddy bears I'm getting
close to the end I hope I think I pray
I'm thinking there might have been ik
another teddy bear in the washroom or
something I don't know what is this the
bar oh good
seven of nine
just two more I don't know where I'm
gonna find the other two I've been in
almost every room I must have missed
something in the pitch blackness ah baby
I'm a big baby I cry like a baby
what does I good yeah go to hell you
died no thank you
there was no other key I got nothing
else i got nothing i got nothing
I'm two bears short and I am going to
die somehow horribly I'm gonna be
horribly mangled as a little baby I saw
that ah coming for you
oh look ditch ax maybe job shop who's
doing that why
ah oh come on but he didn't even get
close to me [ __ ] that [ __ ] everything
about that then no no no no give me out
here
I don't wanna thank you get me back to
here I can see what you all wanted me to
play that but I'm not going back
ever no I refuse I can do that I can
refuse to do that maybe I think probably
but no I'm not going you can you can see
the ending from someone else no I'm not
going back so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation come on
videos it I've done and as always I will
see you in the next video
up here
not your girl
bud
you